is it
a meteor shower space debris
no it's something much much
worse our nearest neighbor
is a full moon no more
the moon exploded and splintered into
millions of fragments
enormous lunar rocks are hurtling toward
earth
could this wipe us off the face of the
planet
how could the moon explode in the first
place
and if we do survive how would losing
the moon
change life as we know it this
is what if and here's what would happen
if the moon
exploded okay so
how on earth did the moon blow up
a blast mining operation gone wrong a
nuclear blast
a collision with a rogue planet whatever
caused this catastrophe
you'd have to be packing some serious
firepower to
blow up the moon guns
lots of guns the largest nuclear bomb
ever built the tsar bomba had the energy
of over
57 million tons of tnt
think that's strong enough it's just a
drop in the ocean compared to the
amount of force you'd need to blow up
the moon
you'd need the power of over 600 billion
sar bombas to destroy the moon with
anything less than that the moon would
just crack into pieces
and its gravity would pull it back
together again
but if someone or something
managed to explode the moon ah
it would spell bad news for us
the moon debris would scatter across the
solar system
some into the abyss of outer space
and some headed straight for earth
earth's gravitational pull would
immediately start to attract the moon
rocks
as the moon's remains start to pick up
speed
they would come crashing down into the
atmosphere luckily
most of the smaller debris would burn up
before it reaches us
any larger pieces that got through would
be traveling much slower than a similar
sized asteroid
the damage they'd cause wouldn't amount
to much
but is it just me or is it getting a
little hot in here
the moon chunks aren't causing much
damage but the
endless barrage of debris on our
atmosphere would
start to heat up the earth the whole
world would start to get hotter
and hotter eventually getting to the
point of
incinerating all life talk about a bad
way to go
oh and if you're thinking about trying
to evacuate earth
you better do it as soon as possible the
moon debris
combined with all the satellites it
would destroy in space
would make any trip out nearly
impossible
but what if you did manage to get out of
dodge or
hunker down in the deepest parts of the
earth
what would life be like in the aftermath
well for some of us it wouldn't get any
cooler
the moon helps stabilize the earth's
axial tilt
it's what gives us seasons with a new
tilt
some parts of the earth could be
constantly exposed to the sun
in the worst case the polar regions
could start
rapidly melting raising sea levels
and drowning out parts of the world
as the debris settles the skies could
look a little different
the remaining moon rock might cluster
around the earth
forming a giant ring like saturn
but don't stop and stare too long
every once in a while some of the debris
could rain down onto the earth
over billions of years the moon's
gravitational pull
slowed down the earth's rotation giving
us
our 24-hour days without the moon
the earth would start to rotate faster
and faster
we'd have shorter days and stronger
winds
birds and insects would have a tough
time
surviving the harsh winds not only that
ocean tides would start to die down into
tiny little waves
the moon's gravity helps create tides on
earth
bummed out that you can't rip some
gnarly waves anymore
well dude there'll be a much bigger
problem
it would wipe out all of the sea
creatures that rely on the tides and
ocean currents for survival our whole
world would be literally
flipped upside down the earth would burn
up
our days would be shorter and the moon
wouldn't be there to light up the night
sky
[Music]
now that we know how devastating it
would be if the moon exploded
what if instead of having no moon we had
two well that's a story
for another what if